herzlich konzern folge ich fahre leute
an einem wunderschönen sommer nachmittag
/ abend in köln kölner dom hinter uns
wir sind auf einem traumhaften parkdeck
wir dass sich unter dem motto was geht
die kritik hielt und du hast uns heute
einen sehr exotischen wagen mitgebracht
schwenken einmal eintrüben und sehen ein
maserati ghibli transport sc 4.4
[Musik]
und das ist eine sehr sehr sehr sehr
geile wahl muss ich sagen bevor wir
umgehen sagt mal warum genau das auto
also das hauptargument war tatsächlich
dass ich einfach ein auto wollte was was
exklusiver ist weist wir einfach etwas
besonders ist irgendwie weil man sieht
halt hier auch vor allem in großstädten
köln immer wieder die gleichen markt ja
ja und er wollte einfach speziell ist
geil und dann auch in kombination mit
einem auto das alltagstaugliches weißt
du ja wenn ich jetzt irgendwas
spezielles was sich mclaren oder so
gucke leisten das ist ein auto das sich
alltagstaugliches kleiner kofferraum und
leiter mit dem auto habe ich so alles in
einem und das war der perfekte
kompromiss und die dann noch brutal aus
und deswegen habe ich mich dafür
entschieden übels im westen ja leute
kommen wir schon mal kurz probiert in
hier vorne der drei zeigt das wisst ihr
ja klassisches maserati warten hier
einmal fett vorne im kühlergrill drin
und nochmal als waffen im emblem hier
einfach sexy alter weiß schwarze
kombination rote bremsbacken sehen wir
hier unten richtig richtig geil gelochte
bremsscheiben ja das ist ein unfassbarer
schönes auto muss man sagen fun factory
ich habe ein bisschen recherchiert für
das video und maserati sagt auf ihrer
website im konfigurator den slogan sie
sind nicht wie jeder andere ja das sieht
man auch an den zulassungszahlen vom
giebel das übrigens der dritte gewinn
also die dritte generation vom gebiet
wurden ich glaube von 2013 bis 2019 nur
knapp über 4000 stück zugelassen in
deutschland zum vergleich dazu der audi
a6 was mitbewerber von dem es obere
mittelklasse von dem boden mit damit es
66 aber allein in 2020 über 30.000
zugelassen also ist er aber ist sehr
geil sind sehr halb drauf hier diese
klassischen maserati team hier unten
sehen wir grand sport eine von drei
ausstattungsversionen es gibt den
normalen ghibli gerade lust so lustiger
ähnlich für luxus und den gran sport
dass die sportliche variante kommt mir
das ist halt auch kommen also diese
hätte c-säule hier und dann nochmal den
dreizack drauf das ist geil dabei grand
sport hat auch brembo bremsen drauf und
430 ps v6 motor entwickelt von ferrari
gebaut von ferrari 550 newtonmeter
drehmoment ja dicke dinger maserati ist
halt so es war fast wie crazy so hatte
zu jeder marke so ein urteil so lange so
voll die fresse ferrari so bisschen
eleganter formel einzige aber man fragt
sich eigentlich so was ist maserati
eigen hat sich auch nicht so auf dem
schirm ja also das kam jetzt ganz später
sich auf die idee kamen wie sie zeigen
mit maserati auf krasse waldecker ich
erinnere mich noch wir haben auch also
wir kennen ja auch schon ne weile haben
zwar früher unterhalt über autos und du
mind ist das komplett eigentlichkeit von
jaja komplett nicht so denn von corvette
auf die corvette kam halt nur die g8 in
frage die ganz neu jahren und das ist ja
noch gar nicht so auf dem europäischen
markt und so weiter ja ich habe sogar
mich über import erkundet und so weiter
übel ist der stress haider soll dann
habe ich die amerikanische version und
so weiter deswegen das hätte gedauert
bis der auf den deutschen markt kommt
oder die fremdheit und dann habe ich
mich heute arbeite ich geguckt aber
corvettes davor so mein traumauto
gewesen richtig geil alter aber ich
finde die wahl auch so für mich als auto
fährt muss ich sagen richtig geile wahl
hammer finde ich feiere ich richtig 280
reifen drauf 21 zoll felgen voran haben
hier einen look vorne 245 interessant
also unterschiedliche reifendimension
obwohl es ein allrad ist das q4 im namen
des q4 steht für allrad als ist ein
variabler allrad drin hängen allrad der
interessanterweise aber standardmäßig
die hinterachse antreibt weil die
meisten variable allradsystem wie beim
quattro zum beispiel beim audi a3 wird
ja die vorderachse angetrieben und die
hinterachse zugeschaltet hier ist genau
andersherum hinterachs wird angetrieben
und dann bei grip verlust bei der
unterschied in den achsen wird die
vorderachse zugeschaltet bis 50% geil
digger ich finde das ist einfach eine
geile wahlmann das ist einfach geil da
erst mal reinschauen genau gebe die
obere mittelklasse leute also wie gesagt
a6 5er bmw e klasse mitbewerber und guck
mal hier was ein innenraum bruder
sascha
geil hier carbon alt wird mir carbon
schaltwippen sport halten aber es ist
immer noch an sich ein mitbewerber vom
a6 das verrückt wird können wir ein
setzen ja klar weil
das schon pornos guckt mal leute hier
das finde ich auch richtig sexy hier mit
so einer kleinen leder käppi auf leder
cap drüber eine analoge uhr mit dem
dreizack und überall wie gesagt das
maserati logo barbara hier ist das handy
staufach na ja da kommt das handy rum
war auch diese tür kummer und bowers &
wilkins jbl soundsystem
pattaya der kanal gut 3 3 system gps
gibt es normale dann gibt's nach wie
heißt es links harman kardon was auch
bei bmw gibt und dem säntis bowers &
wilkins was was macht hier drin hat und
das ist richtig richtig kraft habe ich
mir sagen lassen als ausstattungs mäßig
schon holt er school mit karbon innen
und alles der hat ja 90.000 basis circa
genau und der schweiz mit ausstattung
bei 128 1128 her es ist ein fucking
geile war also ganz ehrlich ich glaube
ganz viele autoliebhaber von euch
draußen hatten auch diesen wagen noch
nicht so super auf dem schirm und werden
ihnen möglicherweise richtig geil finden
nach diesem video schauen wir weiter ich
mache hier einmal zu
mitgefühl rahmenlosen scheiben hinten
und vorne glaube ich auch noch keinen
geil kann man auch mit zu fünft dritte
sitzen also ist theoretisch elga projekt
wirklich prächtig hab das auto dann
kannst du vieles mitnehmen dann direkt
also wenn ich eine frage hätte ich damit
aufgehört muss ich sagen
in hamburg geholt ja ja genau genommen
warum leute hier maserati in hamburg
kennzeichenhalter übrigens mit dem ich
fahre platzhalter premiere zum ersten
mal und jetzt einmal drücken genau und
ist überraschend groß fand ich als ich
dir ja auch erst mal gut mal reinschaut
also richtig geilen tatsächlich sogar
dinge damit transportieren 500 liter
kofferraumvolumen glaube ich finde ich
ziemlich exakt sofort hier rechts die
handbücher maserati berg sowie bei
ferrari im kofferraum die tasche mit dem
nahe man kennt die italiener lassen wir
noch mal das heck auf uns wirken das ist
anders als in asco achten wir letztens
hatten gar kein fake man sieht aber noch
die klappen was weiß was film oder
modell ja das ist also dann wurde er
gebaut
2020 nehmen echt sonstiger aber er hat
doch klappen hinten drin eigentlich
klappen anlage ist eigentlich verboten
oder egal wo man hinterfragen also viel
zeit und
wir auf jeden fall dieses auto ist von
2016 ja mit knappen anlage drin
italiener gibt es da vielleicht
irgendwie sonderregeln hex hex auch nice
sehr breit erinnert mich so in seiner
wuchtigkeit fast ein bisschen an den
gt-r
warm sodass ich bin auch also davon
sofern werden auto auch wuchtig ist
nicht klein sondern wenn es einfach leid
lang und schwer ist so ja mag ich also
das ist dass der filter hat auch geil
digger und aber leute ich habe es schon
mal gesehen aber ich muss noch mal die
front anschauen also innenraum geil aber
der vor allem die front ist es diese
front perspektive schwarz-weißes
wechselspiel und dieser grill digger
marschall eine sache würde ich mich gern
auch machen bevor wir los fahren zwar
klar ja okay das auto ja leute neugierig
hat so eine art ganzen regentage wir
jetzt haben ist letzter
[Musik]
geiler sound megageil danke dir das war
das sollte eine letzte sache zeige ich
noch zweimal im blick hier in den
innenraum hier sehen wir es noch mal
keine erinnerungshilfe für alle die es
vielleicht vergessen v6c drin und vorher
gesunde
ist auch war ja nicht gelogen mit
ferrari so sind sogar die logos drauf ja
mega geil jetzt gerade zum fahren let's
go und da sind auch schon leute die
erste frage ist immer was bedeutet es
für dich als erst muss ich ich muss mal
klagen über diese autofahrt oder weil so
richtig für
autos also ich bin nicht der typ der
ultra finow hat alle details immer bis
ins ende weiß sondern so ich finde ich
finde autos wie viele menschen immer ja
sehr geil als kind habe ich immer
richtig you thought we'd gespielt weißt
du ja
sport
genau und ich habe viele autos gespielt
so hantsch es ein schönes auto sky das
zu besitzen immer ein traum gewesen so
und jetzt habe ich mir das einfach mal
ermöglicht geil und bin mit meiner
entscheidung jetzt nach drei monaten
fällt das auto sehr sehr happy
deswegen also es gibt ja schon viel wert
wenn ich im auto sitze also das macht
echt spaß freue mich auf jede jede fahrt
ohne den eindruck habe ich auch und du
hast ja echt sehr schönes stück
italienischer ingenieurskunst muss
übrigens auch noch an werken der stelle
die sitze diesen so richtig sofa haft
also man singt da wirklich so rein so
der lounge zum first class lounge am
flughafen
ich geil finde ich geil weil der ddr
üblich ist ja kein kein brett harter
sportler so das ist eine sportliche
limousine aus der mittlere oberklasse so
sagt man es ist
vor allem auch komfortabel finde ich
richtig geil genau eine sache die leute
auch immer interessiert ist
wie du die wanne zugelegt hat das sind
das jetzt ganz viele also ist das jetzt
ein leasing ist das ist das in kauf wenn
du dich wohl fühlst das zu sagen thema
versicherungen wir gerade optimal
eingestellten kannst du auch gerne was
erzählen ja also es ist ein leasing
wagen das ist das was so noch einen
kalkulationen für mich am meisten sinn
ergeben hat klar ist auch geschäftlich
da natürlich ja und da macht so am
meisten sinn genau dann ging es halt
darum als ich den hatte und um das thema
versicherung das ist alles ein bisschen
special weil es ja was dann hat das
schon zu anfang das ist halt ein auto
was nicht so ultra viel zugelassen ist
und bei diesen speziellen autos ist das
immer so dass viele versicherungen
den gar nicht zum versichern anbieten
weil sie sich dann halt eher auf die
autos konzentrieren die auch viele in
deutschland gefahren werden und deswegen
bin ich über maserati selber haben diese
eigene versicherung eigene deals und da
hatte ich auch keine große auswahl und
habe mich dann am ende für eine
entschieden
aber das war schon rasch und so ein
bisschen jahren struggle auf jeden fall
mit dem mit versicherungen also wenn du
bei check24 dass auch ich weiß nicht wie
das jetzt ist aber zu dem zeitpunkt wo
ich
recherchiert hatte habe ich mal check24
den eingegeben und da war einfach war
kein angebot
das machen das wurde mir beim alten auto
zum verhängnis dass ich nur teilkasko
versichert hier stimmt die geschichte
magst du dir auch erzählen ja klar kann
ich also ich hatte halt letztes jahr ein
auto unfall nicht verschuldet also ich
auf der autobahn linke spur und dann
kann man das ja wenn da jemand einfach
zum überholen quasi direkt vor der
auszieht und der wahrheit der wahl
gefühlt 80 km h schnell ich mit 160 auf
den spuren hat mir wahrscheinlich
gesehen ich vollbremsung war bmw wenn
auch wie man es halt in der in dieser
kurzschlussreaktion macht habe das
lenkrad nach rechts gezogen um ihm
auszuweichen was ich vielleicht nicht
hätte tun sollen und dann fährt man
lieber einem hinten rein anstatt dass
man ja auf der autobahn mit 160 voll in
den drift geht und da ja wenn dann halt
wirklich über die autobahn geschleudert
rechts in die leitplanke geknallt
und genau ja ich glaube einmal auf
karbon nicht überschlagen ja sehr gut
und ich bin ausgestiegen hatte nicht der
typ ist weitergefahren also ein fahrrad
5 tatsächlich quartal kaskoversichert
haben nichts bekommen aber es passiert
so am ende des tages bin ich gesund und
das ist das allerwichtigste hat
wahrscheinlich gar nichts mitbekommen
der zeit wenn ich mich ein bisschen
hörbuch gehört ja oder vielleicht ja ja
also ich hab noch gehupt das weiß ich
noch danach war alles da ging alles so
schnell kräftiger also das war mein
einziger autounfall bisher und das ist
ein ganz will das gefühl wenn du sonst
immer nur irgendwie das gesehen hast du
die nachrichten oder irgendwas vor dir
passiert ist aber so involviert ist das
geht so schnell alles ist ganz
verrücktes gefühl sein denn war das für
mich natürlich noch mal ein anlass jetzt
hole ich mir ein neues auto ja und
danach sogar direktor ja genau und jetzt
immer wenn ich linke autobahnspur werden
immer mit einem fuß auf der bremse
aber jetzt machen wir auch mehr platz
ok geil
geil sehr geile schiff zum
der eine hat sehr sehr geil ich bin ich
bin gespannt auf den fahreindruck leute
ich bin ja bis juni dieses jahres bis
vor sieben monaten auch ein v6 eine
sportlich muss ich hier gefahren den c
43 amg und bin sehr gespannt wer jetzt
so ein vergleich dazu sein wird ja aber
die angespannten eindruck ich bin halt
noch nicht so viele autos gefahren ja
für mich ist er als das ist ja wohl
wehrte sich fuld raschen aber ich habe
halt auch nicht so super viele
vergleichswerte ja also ich bin mal
gespannt was du denn dazu sagt so geht
cavani
ich muss sagen für dann muss man das
mikro umstecken für italienische
verhältnisse erwartet man eigentlich
klassenkassen motor krasse emotionen und
eigentlich es verarbeitung ist so
überhaupt hier nicht überhaupt nicht
klappt ja also habe ich von einem gehört
dass die verarbeitung schlecht sein soll
aber also kann ich auch nicht so
bestätigen also maserati hat sich aber
auch echt gemacht muss man sagen ja die
waren die sie haben ein richtiges
comeback hingelegt so die waren echt ok
an er will auf jeden fall nach vorne
echt sehr linear finde ich fertig das
ist
krass
kaum war die sonne geht und jetzt sind
wir langsam wir außerorts muss ich das
drücken was muss ich machen versprochen
wir das erhofft haben so ja jetzt mal
scharf
geil
geil geil geil geil aber wirklich sehr
sehr sehr linear muss man sagen also gar
kein garnichts knobeloch atomanlagen
sind aber wissen wieder runter das thema
oder 40 mal sind wir auch machen
das ist eine sehr gute idee das ist ein
sehr guter fortschritt launch control
& co
ja komm
jack eines schiffs
die schiffe sind sehr powervollen ja
heftig ist es voll absurd für italiener
einfach der ist so komfortabel
krank bibel ist geil isoliert es ist
echt schick und älter
boah
dieses schiffs stärken
ja
jawohl
das krasse ist glaube ich man hört
glaube ich ihnen viel weniger als auch
wirklich sehr gut isoliert aber die
feste auf das hört man auch mal was
außen ab und zwar jetzt
what the [ __ ] also das hätte ich hätte
nicht erwartet dass es so krass lautes
die jäger er sitzt hier wirklich drin
und da ist nichts fast gar nichts als
wärs drei zimmer weiter dass einer
seinen maserati fährt dann macht ihr die
fenster auf was ich gerade schon die
umwelt terrorisiert heroin es zu merken
[Musik]
was ein abriss alter da ist ja ganz
aggressiv
ja welche
ja geil finde ich geil das ist kein bmw
geworden ist ja also und damit meine ich
jetzt noch hier dann alle bmw boss aber
das ist so man feiert ja auch als
autodieb aber wenn man auch exotische
autos mal erscheinen in der stadt soeben
sky ja damals fiel vielen dank danke
fürs dabei sei er ja danke fürs preis
wirklich hammergeil wahl muss ich sagen
und wer weiß vielleicht ist ein risiko
das hätte ich gehabt macht mir ein
bisschen verrückter scheiß und eine
auspuffanlage darunter nochmal übrigen
drauf leider nicht nur zumindest
offiziell für das
alles gute leute oder abhängige werte
platz gehabt die bewertung beginnt wie
immer mit dem aus leute und da habe ich
wirklich lange lange gekämpft und bin
zwischen zwei werten hin und her
geschwankt der disco 4 ist ein sehr sehr
sehr schönes auto das muss man so klar
sagen ich habe wie gesagt wirklich ne
weile gebraucht ich habe ich mit
freunden bereitschaft ich habe mich hin
und her gewählt und am ende bin ich bei
neun von zehn angekommen einfach weil es
wirklich ein sehr sehr sehr schönes auto
ist gerade in der kombi weiß mit
schwarzen felgen roten bremssätteln mega
die beschleunigung ist zügig das war
auch zu erwarten dass ist ein allrad mit
430 ps 4 7 sekunden von null auf hundert
das ist schnell aber nicht
außerordentlich schnell und gibt eine
sieben von zehn die kühl dass leute
wieder eine kategorie wo der maserati
mich erwischt hat das muss ich einfach
zu geben mich interessieren dabei jetzt
auch bei diesem video ganz besonders
eure meinung schnapp dir gerne in die
kommentare wie hättet ihr den maserati
in den sechs kategorien bewertet weil
der kunde ist sehe ich definitiv das ist
ein sehr exotischer wagen ist der
gebläsen sehr seltener wagen maserati
ist irgendwie schon so eine luxus
sportliche marke die man aber auch nicht
so oft sieht das finde ich halte
persönlich mega cool und gebt
dementsprechend hier neun von zehn spaß
wird und dementsprechend 25 von 30 und
infolgedessen platz sieben was für ein
allrounder wie der gegner ist sehr sehr
stark ist die praktikabilität ist gut
man hat nicht überdimensioniert viel
platz wie zum beispiel im s8 aber man
hat einen viertürer mit 500 litern
kofferraumvolumen das ist schon echt
alltagstauglich muss man ganz klar sagen
man kriegt genug leute haben man kriegt
genug sachen hinten auch eingeladen also
sieben von zehn preis leistungen gegen
ein bisschen schwierig weil die masse
rat ist auch gerade in vergangenheit
dafür bekannt war dass sie mit richtig
krassen wertverlust haben andererseits
muss ich sagen hat der wagen mich auch
einfach so geflasht weil es eine geile
exotische alternative für die obere
mittelklasse ist auch wenn die natürlich
bisschen teurer ist als jetzt sagen a 6
war er so viel kostet wie ein gut
ausgestatteter sex oder rs6 bin ich
trotzdem vom gesamtpaket gut überzeugt
und wie gesagt mit der vorwarnung für
den wertverlust gebe ich sechs von zehn
der komfort ist wirklich sehr stark wie
man es auch endlich erwarten würde von
einem wagen der oberen mittelklasse der
wagen ist absolut genial isoliert man
bekommt geteilt wird es vermutlich
selber mal die umwelt terrorisiert mit
seinem sound allerdings muss man sagen
die 21 zoll felgen führen dazu dass man
gerade so kleine unebenheiten direkt
durchgegeben bekommt und es ist kein
unfassbar komfortables auto dadurch
sieben von zehn sind denke ich ein
fairer wert hier damit kommen wir der
alltags wertung auf 20 von 30 und platz
sechs und insgesamt auf 45 von 60 und
auf einen sehr sehr sehr starken platz
in der top 3 nur noch geschlagen vom
audi s8 und vom gt 63 s viertürer der
maserati gbs q4 ist schon sehr sehr sehr
frisches autor schreibt eure meinung zu
den waren die kommentare wäre das was
für euch ist es zu exotisch fehlt euch
irgendwas und bis zum nächsten sonntag
läutet kurs geht raus an euch